[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre j ph canter et
moi dôme plan aujourd'hui on reçoit jean
philippe setbon jour bonjour les amis ma
télé vous habille toi très bien pour moi
que la technique la fillette est un chef
des gan oui c'est un auteur de l'est de
là cet auteur culinaire auteur culinaire
pour toi qui lui n'a rien dit you tube
house un plaisir six mois de la saison
de se déchaîner la fin les meilleurs
comme un conte présent choisir sa date
août et s'est dit victime du docteur ou
non quand tu veux si vous aimez ce que
vous entendez n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner au sans fil podcast porte les
nouvelles des nouveau podcast concert à
toutes les mardis puis aussi donné des
commentaires participer aux discussions
on aime se voulait on aime ça interagir
avec vous est ce un philippe merci pas
de l'église ce vendredi matin c'est bon
parfait donc j'en ai mondial du
véganisme aujourd'hui je savais pas
pantoute mois on a réajusté on a rejoint
le premier avant je savais pas jusqu'à
temps que tout le monde m'appelle pour
des entrevues genre hier soir
var matin et qui avec radio canada sort
de la phase de toujounine hautes tantôt
que je passe sa première année que c'est
ça la force que moi j'ai c'est sûr que
j'étais moins attentifs à ça mais
parfois j'entends parler la journée
mondiale vais gagner chaque à la journée
mondiale des pois chiches des
légumineuses
je sais pas j'ai peu de vidéos là dessus
mais il manque vraiment d'imagination
ces journées monte à la journée mondiale
des pois chiches en mettant en même
temps je pense honnêtement maintenant
que je cuisine vegan je pense que les
pois chiches mérite vraiment une journée
mondiale contre les putschistes en
israël les pois chiches l'humus falafel
c'est tout des falafels gamme active pas
aimer les falafels sétif riz c'est un
morceau de quelqu'un qui m'a dit les
restaurants fermerait le venin 24 system
- système moins chiant de faire cela je
t'ai chez vous le faire frire chez vous
c'est comme ça ça ouais mais ça me
semble pas billy bishop est à remarquer
quand tu fais quelque chose je mesure
attendue et l'a20 et après le raid
pendant ce temps-là 2007 qu'un team des
recettes sur internet souvent je vois
pas obligé de le faire sauf un petit peu
d'huile dans une plaque
mettez fallait faire tourner d'abord à
mi-cuisse ans après jobs jobs dhifallah
fait parce qu'il fallait fait ça absorbe
les patates déjeuner ouais parenthèse
nous marier parce que c'est une frite
une quantité de vies qu'elle l'afrique
peut absorber
c'est tout des petits morceaux les
restes 1 en attendant le petit boire
mais les patates déjeuner quand tu
achètes seul sait le papier est dégueu
laitiers plus tu peux pas le manger s'en
vont les doigts en direct son gré ce
pendant trois heures après seattle temps
les suivait partout il ya suisse ou sur
le mur le bec sûr que nous savons c'est
assez grave
ratliff sa poule 2
faut faire attention à ce qu'on fait
parce que les gens ils font attention
pour juste alors la robine ce qui manque
mais est ce que tu penses qu'il ya une
je pense en fait c'est parce qu'une sur
mise en garde par rapport à certaines
affaires - le gaz émis un micro-ondes
emmené dans une demi heure c'est tout
l'objet des menaces de mort
ah ouais ben voyons dans à cause des
coûts tfou les gens oseraient qui
confondre vegan en plus ouais ouais
confondre s'est rendu vers yann
s'épanouit qu'on ne pouvait pas avec les
migrants si c'était dangereux microbes
en train de gagner est malade le il
yad'énormes il ya
joe rogan dans l'afrique italie par des
micro ondes qui ne de glace explique
vraiment bien la science micro-ondes
puis à quel point il n'y a aucune raison
de s'inquiéter que c'est juste qu'une
fréquence et crée une pression des
molécules d'eau qui fait que ça ça
réchauffe mais qui sait pas comment ça
marche c'est dangereux tout l'imaginaire
c'est normal qu'un micro-ondes comprend
pas nécessairement comment ça fonctionne
c'est clair s'est passé quoi
higgins ouais ya beaucoup de monde que
pense la terre est plate et encore on
attend plus parler je veux moi j'ai deux
côtés j'ai un compte enfin français
pendant que j'étais en engrais le one
shot qui canada sont plus ignore si je
mets du tofu de soyaux bouger comme la
mafia du seuil de l'indicé you qui me
sortent de shana anglais bayer plus d'un
monde fait que c'est démocratique et
plus de will do il ya plus de jeunes
s'est dit genre de profil avec un show
où quelque chose je veux te suit le bleu
tu vas voir s'il ya dix ans j'ai des
valeurs
palard non ce polar et le renard leurs
photos moi je me souhaite stocker
personnage ma part quelqu'un sur
internet sur internet se savait pas
d'abord testé comme massa s'est suicidé
à cause de toi mais c'est quelqu'un qui
avait un problème mental une fan quand
j'ai réussi des doués que cette même
personne parce que des fois il y avait
comme des photos floues psas arabes les
plus jeunes seraient stockées sur toutes
les plateformes par différentes
personnes qui ont tout défaut quand
parce que des conséquences japonaise
était quand même journée ok quelque
chose qui se passe mais faut que tu
gères ce parce que j'ai environt store
site web ils vont partir des listes des
énormités mais ces commentateurs que ça
ternit tapage un peu c'est chiant aussi
le chien c'est une autre pendant bannac
passion des objets manquants chic quand
je suis sorti j'ai fait la rétrospective
un peu des médias sociaux le puits avait
cinq comptes qui était créé à peu près
d'un même date 0 a mis au jour deux amis
en commun qui à chaque semaine 6 5
contre là c'est mon beau frère qui a
fait l'étude qui avec qui je veux pas
c'est qu'à chaque semaine ces cinq
comptes lui utilisé le même langage pour
me bâché - les cinq contes à chaque
semaine chaque fois exposé quelque chose
c'est tout le talent la même affaire
fait que c'est sûrement une personne
mais mes poches et e5 en cours hier
matin
ouais ouais j'ai fait pire facebook
n'est même pas se poser de 6,5 se donner
un pseudonyme parce que disposer de ce
serait peut-être identitaire c'est
bizarre
et c'est fou ce que tu déjà eu une
parole et été j'ai des fois ça allait
trop loin piqué le tpir all blacks en
jalles en israël n est pas si j'étais
invité en israël pour promouvoir le
véganisme au téléphone par agnès b l
ailier des groupes qui ont dit que je
t'ai six analystes
puis qu'acheter une poudrière la baule
est très controversé pie pas controversé
pied des groupes que ils se disent ça il
ya des influenceurs qui arrive et qu'on
va utiliser leur plateforme qui est des
grandes plateformes pour faire pour
hijack et le message d'attirer
l'attention sur notre message de l'asa
avait pris des proportions mais tout le
monde qui vont les restes anthony
bourdain jamaran ''serait il ya des
régions comme ce que les jeunes qui
hésitent à y aller parce que tu es
victime de représailles même si moi je
fais pas de politique je t'avais là avec
une gang de youtube art mais la
politique tu es rattrap parce que tu
demandes qui vont politisé tout ce que
tu fais c'est un bon très bon véhicule
pour des gens qui ont une cause à
défendre et à jack et des profils des
gens connus qui ont des gros for loving
parce qu'ils ont ils sont pas capables
d'attirer l'attention sur leur message
mais quand tu rien te reprocher au japon
de gestion de crise à faire parce que
j'ai rien fait de mal là-dedans c'est
comme si youtube font des affaires
croche peu sont obligés de faire des
vidéos de pour le gisement tout ce que
tu as eu besoin de faire c'est juste un
blog de ta journée
ça valait vraiment cool to you love qui
a annulé son show en israël qui dément
les prix la décision peut y aller qui
avait ri des os qui allait faire des
chambres à air
il savait était de pink floyd qui a fait
les trous verte le a good with you est
pour l'heure au banana
moi je peux pas me prononcer parce que
je le connais pas assez le climat un
impôt aussi qu'il ya une distinction
entre la population peeling décision du
gouvernement s'est offert un show de
musique rock le tout ça veut pas dire
que tu as pu quoi que ce soit ça fait
qu'ils savaient juste déguisements
labaki qui trippent ce thème musique et
il va partager ce puits ce monde le data
centre allemand même pas d'accord avec
les décisions du gouvernement et baker
lui et quelques années avec la
souveraineté y avait des prises de
position puis des affaires qui fait le
point prenez position d'un côté nathalie
aînés toute l'audience la musique saint
jean baptiste la fête du canada
c'est moi je vais vous autres mais moi
j'étais là 4 le référendum a manqué par
ac puis c'était le sujet de la libye
c'est la raison pour laquelle de moins
en mois j'ai toujours considéré mettons
de gauche mais toujours considéré
mettons souverainiste qui je la fiche de
moins en moins pichot même de moins en
moins m'identifie de moins en moins et à
des groupes d'amis ou des positions
parce que dès que 10e
créer une opposition qui dit crise c'est
comme si la droite mais on peut faire
une offre conjointe qu'on est d'accord
mais la fab qui on échange mais correct
mais le moment tu dis si c'est comme
wind cries deux clans je pense du moment
qu'ils prennent position dans n'importe
quoi tu des bols paris - pensez quoi
trois choses qu'il faut que tu veux te
parler aux fêtes politique et religion
et alimentation les gains c'est la
dualité mois quand vous autres
- moi j'suis majorque tout parce que moi
je marche je nous donne un jeu de laver
un pays beaucoup de vegan qui sont nés
vegan non vraiment tout d'un coup vous
[Musique]
c'est exact je me suis mal placé pour
faire la morale à un an je suis un
terrible à l'uqam
non mais c'était ça pourrait être sympa
c'est ce qu'on veut des gueux qui
cuisinent dirige
mais oui ça n'en est rien de fait on ton
dernier post sur pourquoi ya pas plus de
gueule survécu ça a été quand même
virale se posent les wii parce que je
cours d'une entrevue un journal puis
pourquoi que ya pas plus de go ce que je
vois mon camp je fais des signatures de
livres jan25 fille go gamondi après
pâques en talent est là mais juste au
festival vegan quand je talent et je
suis allé voir la démo clean air de gaz
aux clés puis quand je suis sorti il y
avait à peu près une file de 300
personnes qui attendaient pour être unis
pour faire signer le relais par gazeau
klepis c'était que toi mais ce saut gaz
un peu la charte ya plus de photos j'ai
des photos mais mais mais même qu'un de
ses potes joue pas la carte des diggers
enfin quelque chose puis j'essaie
l'articuler aussi parce que les gars
souvent c'était le faisait à bouche est
restée au qui faisait un central mais ce
fait pas longtemps que le monde il ya
bâti un cache on encore chez eux y
compris
c'était le gars qui faisait des palais
qui écrase un peu sa compassion on
écrase un peu de côté motif justement
pour parce qu'il faut que quelqu'un le
fasse pas les quelques faces d'un ballet
quelqu'un et la chasse je pense qu'un
enfant ça effet la première fois j'étais
à la pâte je n'avais pas le poisson
j'avais pas la pharma l'aubois
simplement pas un accident c'est un
poisson c'est comme sa compagne
jusqu'aux plates excuses
mélo tapera pu être empathique 7 à
prinquiau l'empathie non c'est pas dans
cette école
ouais pilote qui grandit avec ce puits
là après un game 7 ans va manger des
ailes de poulet plutôt non moi je dois
prendre des ailes de tofu surtout qu est
un avis radicalement l'autre des toits
ce système en échec aux jeux tama les
dés de poulet c'est sûr d'être les
médias s'est passé c'est plus facile et
devait y incarner une seule chute
brutale blanc ouais que quintin
d'importer de famille société quelqu'un
tu es dans un bar quelqu'un de ta cage
aux sports
ça devient statement chez vous c'est une
manière de vue mais en société en direct
par imposition
les jungles n'y penses que tu prends
position des fois contre aux autres ce
que j'ai fait des progrès que je pas
correct de main jeu de vilain c'est pour
cela lafarge pas parce que t'es pas
correct de manger de la viande c'est
peut-être parce tu comprends pas
pourquoi j'aurais mieux d'en manger
moins d'arrêter d'en manger c'est tout
le cas ce que j'avais cassé les
latitudes ta vie puisqu'elle est arrivé
avec ses thématiques d'être défensive
martin ger n'y a personne qui est pour
la cruauté envers les animaux n'ont
personne non mais c'est quoi c'est quoi
la cruauté envers des animaux
une poule une poule de musique en marge
de la polenta agira comme une feuille
huit et demi par hans wyss je ferai mon
choix je le mets d'anne-k jeux tenus par
an a dit toute sa vie voilà c'est quoi
la cruauté c'est ce prêt une vache
laitière est attaché aux prêts pour
toute sa vie par mon chiffre de la tâche
après un poteau d'un conte chine où le
poisson boksic lui toute sa vie je me
sens chaque fois que je mets en avant
deux ans puis je laisse mon chien
en fait mais c'est ça il ya deux poids
deux mesures c'est les animaux sont pas
tous égaux malheureusement c'est là
c'est pour ça que quand on est pourquoi
on trouve le commun des gens s'ils
mangent encore de la viande parce
qu'ayant paul pourquoi la vraie raison
c'est pourquoi tu arrêter d'en manger
puis d'où les documentaires documentaire
je pense que ça tous attendu au cinéma
c'est juste c'est en sortant en sortant
au début je le faisais juste par respect
pour gc mais en sortant j'ai commencé à
écouter documentaire à mais à lire des
livres là dessus puis une fois que tu
comprends certaines certains concepts de
base après cette neuvième juste une
décision morale que tu prends est-ce que
tu apprends je n'apprends pas mais au
moins tout le monde devrait être au
courant de ces affaires le comprendre
certains concepts puis au moment que tu
comprends quand tu le style et la
cruauté animale
ça ne fait rien il devrait montrer des
écoles pauvres et sur les enfants parce
que c'est des documents pas ces
documents tout seulement parce que c'est
n'importe quoi
non ce qu'il souhaite faire rattraper
nous pouvons vendre notre âme qui loge
fabriquer le canari les documents tasse
et là ça reste s'ils vont trop loin ils
font un soin taper ses doigts sur au
moins que les gens l'écoutent pas prêt
sosa samangan défaut se parlent en bien
des fois ça deux ans plus tard je
devrais
le switch on sait lesquels les meilleurs
maintenant pour vous autres d'esprit si
je pense qu'un clic quelque peu ici
principalement sur l'environnement et de
l'industrie laitière gaulle lyon part
moi c'est moi je suis pas capable à
regarder comprenne qui est celle pour
une raison pour laquelle les jets ya un
médecin internet manger à mes pots parce
que j'ai fait le point j'ai besoin
d'avoir des animaux dans ses selles et
vega ne regarde plus un film était rien
kling rien sorti c'est joaquin phoenix
qu'il narre en anglais là ils viennent
de sortir un nom qui s'appelle dominion
orangé comme si joaquin phoenix qui sort
saucisses et comme terrien mais en 2016
mexès est plus actuelle c'est du
fauteuil j'ai dit c'est comme si tu peux
plus dire ah ouais mais se sait si les
techniques barber d'autrefois le nom
c'est comme si à mayol il se pointe au
québec et aussi de la manne est un
animal qui marche et ce afin de
l'histoire l'animal ma fin du film le
jeune animal qui marche c'est sympa sein
du temps se manger de la viande in el
malki mam au québec
la mentalité dans le monde sait qu'en
robe chez l'animal et à poster tous et
tout le temps ce 6e peut se passer quoi
souffrez soleil c'est la question qui
font que hans questionne les attentes
aussi la souffrance pitié au québec on a
souvent l'idée du swing et du boeuf qui
donne dans nature qui est tellement une
belle vie métier ceci dans l'industrie
du boeuf pense le lacet sic je m'avance
pas mais je pense que c'est 10 % de tout
le boeuf la viande rouge qui est
consommé et fringe
non mais là on est au québec mais french
ça c'est un bon souvenir car nice mme
c'est que bon nombre de ces - paix parce
que c'est bio à l'appui l'avocat sont
ces possibilités
vydra diack les normes c'est quand même
fou qui sont une fois de temps en temps
dehors c'est pas très évident comme
étant le jeu fait vraiment l'avocate
isabelle ici c'est mon opinion mais dans
le commettant de chasse contrôler ou des
populations méthon
populations de cerfs qui sont surpeuplés
pics et détruisent des coups c'est un ex
ante on en a parlé on en a parlé
dernièrement avec carrasso 6 beaufort
qui ont un éthicien preuve d'éthique
animal au collège dawson puis lui ce
qu'il disait c'est que parce que souvent
c'est l'industrie de la fourrure qui
s'occupe de ses charges contrôlés
l'éthique sûr que les charges contrôlés
comme pour à peu près 5% l'industrie de
la fourrure contrôler les populations
avec la lettre à paj contrôler oui je
comprends mais pourquoi tu t'entraînes à
me parler d'un 5% pour qu'on se contente
pas sur le 95 des voix soit on est
pragmatique on va se concentrer sur
l'élevage industriel
si c'est très dommage à pour
l'environnement pour bien-être des
animaux sont des animaux qu'intervint
captivité y ont aucune chance de sauver
il s'arrache les pas tellement sûr
concernant apple fait la chasse puis si
on est obligé de contrôler population ce
parce que en a détruit leurs prédateurs
toutefois la patente des clients peu de
prédateurs la nature casque et roulaient
très bien mais contribuera oui oui mais
là c'est sûr que si on est pogné avec un
problème comme ça mais c'est marginal le
vrai problème c'est le poulet que tu vas
chercher lipsitch les jours sans poser
de questions 2 millions d'animaux par
jour au canada sont abattues la majorité
s'est défoulé pitt c'est dans ce genre
d'argument locity je rentre tout les
mettant moins mais le quai se fait avec
un et nourrir qui qui peut pas cultiver
ck oui je comprends le problème c'est
pas ça le problème c'est que ce problème
puisse et lui a nécessité farceur
séquanien nécessité sucre et sur une île
déserte sert à ma survie ou juste mourir
mais je vais le tuer le cochon pigenel
manger des monos s'est désuni cycle
moyen quand un parent de baisser ma
place
oui mais les unes ici
même proportion
je comprends c'est que là puis pour
revenir sur les documentaires
un documentaire qui s'appelle game
challenger qui est pas encore arrivé ici
puisque docteur greg hors de notre
chemin org a dit que c'était le meilleur
documentaire de nutrition de l'histoire
puis ça s'en vient ça suit je pense un
combattant le team ou quelque chose
comme cela
puis évidemment si c'est prouvé ganis
mais c'est pas prouvée ganis bien et
c'est ça analyse toutes les modes de
diffusion puis celle là c'est comme le
consensus que game challenge ça s'en
vient je pense dans un consensus le
consensus si facile à faire
comme j'ai déjà dit regarde les
américains font au niveau alimentaire
ce fait le contrat si vos des jeux est
pas mal un shape
parce que c'est aussi un vrai problème
d'obésité morbide tkc c'est triste mais
les chalets sont obligés de faire les
chefs trois plus grands volcans mais
celle ci et non pas ce qu'ils peuvent
faire rentrer là-dedans peuvent pas
payer ma blonde et médecin puis fonds
ont déjà fait des congrès puis par de la
barbe aux rebelles
aux etats unis les sections prouvera
plus pauvres un peu trop d'obésité mon
but c'est comme 60% 70% pour boys et
autres cépages et pris 12 lits va nous
aidera c'est comme sans livres de trop
le côté que les stérols dans le fond de
montée des marches une personne hors jeu
qui sont en forme sont plus minces
en général oui parce que c'est pas juste
la longévité c'est quand quelques et les
taux quand va-t-on voir jusqu à 100 afin
que les médicaments
c'est sur un parterre bakel et tout va
vite
moi je comprends mais a pris part pas
avec un radio pau d'ousse québec non
cette liste est qui et qui causent house
et les frites c'est ok c'est tout c'est
pas faux devant l'américain tejay il ya
tout un 2 litres de grosses oui oui
aucun écho qui c'est sûr que le sucre
est dommageable certain que c'est un
ensemble de facteurs mais s'est pas
plainte based non plus du coq puis deux
c'est la seule source naturelle des gras
trans qui le perd gros pour toi c'est
dans les produits animal c'est je
comprends que ces projets soient mais
jamais de chromage enlève le fromage 3,4
mais dans le vestiaire du breton
d'alimentation fromage c'est gros ce ppi
aux états unis à mettre partout dans le
monde sa pizza est un maître d'un pare
d'attributs quelque chose au même
poignet de fromage là d'un payants comme
la seule ayant des recettes c'est comme
de la polenta et c'est comme une farine
de maïs et des frites
il faut emmener de la polenta medispa
maja crème man's man's man's man's man's
world jacques met de la crème
il bosse au pape un pain il coupe ça
encore ils font frire scène africaine
est incroyable c'est combien de calories
par par morceau je subissais des
calories vides
juste du bureau mais aucun moment donné
quand tu étais tv yann titre fut un peu
touffu parce qu'il ya moitié des
calories du boeuf haché en partant on
regarde les valeurs nutritives des fois
pensé web existent eux fut ta garde des
paquets de tofu des mets préparés exito
fut des valeurs collectives sont plus
basses que les calories sont plus basses
pratéenne sont sociales raté ses sauts
des protéines et ses riches en calcium
je trouve moi j'ai jamais mes fromages
de toute ma vie même quand même à 20 que
je devienne vegan fait je te dérange un
traitement toujours détesté toutes
sortes de vandaliser sans fromage
intolérants au lactose vraiment j'aime
pas le goût puis ça j'ai trouvé ça cool
cash est devenu vegas et que 4,9 aux
entretiens tu veux mais du fromage
foxton faut que ce soit un ajouté un
extrait fromage végétalien et moi
j'adore ça c'est carey va prendre ce
plot piché que pas de fromage fromage
non même pas c'est ça la fin du blocage
psychologique ou si le monde n'ont juste
pas parce que le lait fromage et j'en ai
je l'essayé le thé gens mangent des si
elle est seulement faire manger puis ça
goûte la même chose pour moi c'est pas
bon dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
tient au web un mois jamais le fromage
comme le fromage mais c'est pas faux
mais n'a pas mangé pendant deux semaines
se qualifie pas c'est un trip cela fait
trois semaines je mange tous rapids ont
plombé la pizza chez nous après ce vote
passent d'autres choses
c'est même la ville c'est pas tout le
temps tu marches pas un enfer depuis ta
4 intitulé jeudi cinquante et un ans
rédaction est en train d'écrire le
deuxième puis quatre temps en réaction
est ce que je mène à chaque soir tu as
mangé lapide ce que tu veux maintenant
ton les parce qu'il faut que tu as fast
a fait recette non parce que moi général
et ont une recette à l'e3 étaples
c'est maintenant je dois je concept
simple aux jo face au juste aller manger
au restaurant j'ai vu quelque chose je
dois créer une recette - chef ça fait
que je suis mais vite ben chrouda essayé
de tester des arguments pense qu'il faut
pas simplement par raisonnement je me
dis bon ben si c'est plus italien doit
être sociaux je les fais souvent un
premier coup c'est bon pour être
publiable mais je la laisse mûrir un peu
le remède côté je me sens dans mon
cartable puis un moment donné peut-être
un mois plus tard à je resterai cette
loupe de chain paf c'est des fois ça
prend deux ou trois fois mais le teaser
qu'ils ont le leur c'est incroyable
c'est la recette est prête à maturer
mais souvent la première fois tu fais
des tests
c'est bon c'est pas pour que ça soit
extradé
des fois c'est en enlevant des affaires
que tant qu'ils étaient bonifie de crem
la musique mais oui la musique des x men
2 601 racheté be string band racheter
gillet afin d'y laisser longtemps
tâtonné bonnes habitudes
t'as pas besoin de racheter aux bambins
des affaires souvent cantonné recettes
qui est ami l'ingrédient comme je vais
penser des fois c'est parce qu'à la base
d'open bundistes acquire obligé
d'acheter des bons par albert
généalogique éclaté tard rédaction
aspect mat convient de rester à décrire
j'en ai peut-être 75 j'en ai plus que
cela mais un gros j'essaye de quand on y
arrive on essaye de ne pas trop se
répéter non plus me dresse mensah
personnel take you to i want you to
tu vas tu large est un autre danger nos
styles look non ça va être la même
machine
c'est les éditeurs de livres de récidive
a toujours dit m ouais ouais mais
comment enfin saison tu voudrais que
tout est maintenant le chef québécois
vegan québécois iroquois de m
les plus exotiques une chemise
carreautée faudrait que ça soit les 100
meilleures recettes de fèves au lard qui
unifie ce qu'ils sont bons gros sur des
thèmes et les rachète de cabanas chez so
la cabane en cabane de jean-philippe
cheval que choisir comme des années je
comprenne je comprends le principe parce
qu'il ya plein de gens notamment sur le
marché mais comme faire un album c'est
quoi le titre de l'album comme ailleurs
tout cela prenne vraiment moi ça reste
comme fast food ce que je fais c'est
dans ce top est stable puis le premier à
tout le monde en parle
il disait 25 mille copies vendues c'est
énorme ce qu'ils sont ce là tout le
monde en parle mais on ne peut pas
servir de puteaux monde à part pour
allemand numéro 5
bravo l'entrevue je pense que le fait
vraiment bonne impression
je pense que tanner soumah convaincu
beaucoup mais moi je l'aï vue du sud et
au festival vegan ya plein de monde soit
venu me vois un qui dit des choses
ouvertement une personne sur douze 12 il
veut tout le monde aille pas j'ai acheté
j'achète votre lit le on essaye ouais ça
c'est le fun parce que ces réseaux
sociaux savez comment ça fonctionne
c'est comme si comme toujours très
vaguement qui parle comme tout site
cliquer sur vegan voit juste voir des
amis viennent tout le monde daté ami bob
et moi je veux juste la bouriane mon
fils à moi chier fameux gilet chasseur
lui véronique beauvais yann va juste
devoir de la chaîne 3d 4 ou le fait qu
est une émission millions
téléspectateurs le savent a des mains
qui réussit à battre ça montre que les
vega nom n'est pas tout des frites qui
sont dans des sandales est-ce qu'il
fallait qu'on approche aussi c'est que
tu le fais avec oumou tu fais des
couteaux dérision qui prend les
critiques ou les clichés qui fait les
docks avec qui ça passe mieux
le message transmis ce moment là qui est
arrivé avec une attitude de
confrontation on est décédé c'est ça le
but de la pâte en moins de jeu c'est le
moment qui me vient à l'idée à limite
pour être c'est contre-productif de rire
c'est drôle et oui on est tannés des
menaces et si tu souris des vga stop
stop objectif et mon oncle ben ouais
c'est ça ma canne se moquer du monde et
je suis pas bon non plus je me sens bien
dans mon vin est ce que tout ça un
espèce de de challenge des deux côtés
dans ta situation est ce que tu sens que
les vegan les vegan pur et dur on a de
la misère avec ton approche bas au début
je n'avais pas que les gens aiment ce
bon
dépassés veillant ouais ben en fait en
fait je te dis je te demande ça parce
que chez que c'est le genre de chose qui
soit qui sont dites dans un cercle très
restreint de cas mais moi je le plupart
des gens que j'interviewe pour mon
podcast que je rencontre du monde
l'anglais j'en connais du monde qui sont
très très connu mieux vnc des figures
emblématiques les disques la même
affaire dont des biguines paulista
royaume puisse où elle est utilisée
souvent c'est peut-être les nouveaux
vegan qui sont plus extrêmes
ouais parce qu'après un certain temps
moins chaud que c'est contreproductif
maintenant je fais un post mais
quelqu'un qui commande quelque chose
j'ai mangé sur l'autre jour quelqu'un
crier et à sciences po vegan seuil à des
traces de choc aqualad mais je trouve
que ça va des phases un petit peu mon
travail mais j'ai jamais eu de problème
avec des figures extrêmes qui m'ont dit
baye viendront définitivement pas te
dire non non ce serait la toile mais
quand tu commences à avoir du succès
le peso turning prolia un livre qui en
tire est une série très intéressante
peltonen pro bourg est ce quelqu'un tu
deviens professionnelle dans quelque
chose du bord du manque intègre personne
te connais personne qui critique
c'est vrai que quand tu deviens politisé
auxquels fait face le gie du monde qui
m'aiment pas le jus du mans c'est sûr
que c'est pas tout le monde qui va peut
être que votre va être votée maintenant
a martelé fo cela maintenant ça fait
partie ça veut dire que tu en as far as
marche il dit c'est rare que les gens
que les états unis font mieux que tous
comprennent jamais le double de temps
forts l'om qui va venir
la marque donnée de la marque parce que
pas demain c'est du monde sur 20 qui
sont pas connus qui aimeraient se ce
qu'ils font aussi avec ton approche et
camani qui trace une ligne c'est comme
avoir un droit non partant n'a parlé
puis c'est juste russophone c'est le
monde qui les manipulent ils ont été
testés sur des animaux
chris begg arpad prend des pilules tu es
un âne et moi je me mets dans l'optique
où avant que strauss kahn qu'est ce qui
m'horripile el hamman et tu es d'accord
avec ce que les gens disent claude ce
débat tu décroches décroche pas ce que
c'est les jeunes cherchent une espèce de
pureté une espèce de perfection un
concours de la vertu en équivalent à
plus virtuel c'est jessy a fait capoter
mais j'essaie de bloquer un peu les
cahiers des commentaires de manger
league edmond politique sur ce que
j'essaie a fait un post sur ce qu'il a
mangé la crème glacée häagen-dazs vegan
août et puis là il ya un commentaire en
dessous c'est comme et ce avec le sucre
qu'utilise dans ce peut ne pas être des
gannes places et d'un peut ne pas être
des traces et cheveux qu'elle se fasse
rapidement j'ai rentré le succès comme à
chaque fois qui fait qu il faut que tu
prends un produit tout mettons-les les
juges qui sont vegan day que ceux qui
n'ont pas de gélatine qui n'ont pas du
tout le même qui ont passé je dois en
prendre mes yeux du suc dedans mais là
faut que tu ailles sur le site la
compagnie si c'est pas indiqué faut que
tu écriras compagnie pour savoir si leur
ce qu'ils gagnent c'est comme la ccpo
j'avais vu une blogueuse qui essayait
face
un défi vegan la focus est tellement sur
les détails je ne sais pas si tu parles
l'essence un sancerre et de manger du
poulet pas sauvé 200 animaux période est
de manger du boeuf de manger du bacon
avec des oeufs
après sa garde à manger des op art est
laid mais on est rendus d'intras celles
ci on est pragmatique la trace de deux
traces les morceaux qui va sauver des
animaux le jeu suivant des bacs pro doc
/ laitiers cdh monde animal qui a été
dit je sais que ça vient du fait que on
extermine les animaux puis on prend le
bail prodoc de l'animal de l'animal pour
l'utiliser pour faire de génétine faire
des affaires dommages mais si en bout de
ligne au début on arrête de manger des
animaux non plus exactement
moi je pense qui exactement
après je pense que s'ils m'ont arrêtent
de consommer des produits prenant les
animaux comme ça avec les groupes très
justement le suédois des animaux afin de
manger des animaux tout le reste découle
il y aurait plus de demandes pour ceux
qui vont modifier leurs forces et le sud
qui vaille vegan à partir du moment où
est-ce que tu prononces lieu du manque d
épicerie comme en plus il ya plus de
tofu des épiceries de conduite on en
parle maintenant mais je suis sûr et
certain
parlons peu qu est ce qu il faut c paris
la semaine d'après
le port les jobs de passage à l'euro il
ya aussitôt vu général thon rouge
toujours au moins dix quinze fois par
jour julie photo dr c'est sûr que ça
s'appelait au monsieur sa prose enfin
rappelé à tout le monde jeudi le général
d'anjou ont doublé grâce à epernay mène
son lunch l'on sorte des animaux sains
avec des traces empreintes avec manger
de chocolat qui peut contenir que des
faits dans une usine ce que du lait
comme le mandat courait que oui j'ai une
question qui est peut-être niaiseuse qui
vous a sûrement entendu de mille fois
mais je connais pas la réponse
les animaux d'élevage t on les ans les
élèves ont les ans les bruits dit tu es
si on arrête de manger de la viande le
pis tous les projets animaux il veut
rester des animaux domestiques des
animaux sauvages mais clip où les bus
n'aurait pu non mais bon on va arrêter
d'en produire moi c'est pas qu'un animal
qui est bonne et il peut pas surveiller
pas qu'on va arrêter d'en produire pour
avoir moins d'enfants monde pour qu'il y
ait une vie de merde on vraiment c'est
la même chose que les avions anti
médecins animal au monde pour le mettre
dans des cages piste et avec combien de
tabac non ce que je pense et qui va
disparaître et ont ils des vaches qui
sont maintenant qu'ils vont heureusement
gardé pour la navette chez nous avant la
rencontre je pense que l'être humain
puis son cheptel
c'est 93 % des animaux sur la plaine
j'ai pu gagner ou sauvages on a pu 93%
c'est des animaux puis des humains c'est
complètement farfelu on réalise pas à
quel point on est des animaux d'élevage
ça plane et ben non c'est ça la fin
quand tu regardes dernièrement eu aux
etats unis une inondation dans une ferme
de paul
puis il ya eu une chute de drones
aérienne qui montent parce que c'était
tout les paris se noyer play sont tous
deux montés sur le toile puis tu vois le
nombre de porcs sur le toile on dirais
tu sais quand tu vois mettons la
comparaison est quand même ironique mais
quand tu veux mais ton âge un buffet
chinois
tu vois des saucisses cocktail dans son
rôle sa valeur de ce mets ça y en avait
à peu près
6000 que d'un seul toit en train
d'essayer de survivre
je te dis ça c'est dans une ferme à une
place plus probablement qu'un kilomètre
à droite non un autre pendant que
cliente à gauche mais un autre pays
quant à l'idée mais ton de dire tout
l'image la ferme bucolique dachicourt
est ce que comme un breuvage qui se
promène dans le champ c'est pas ce nom
si ces postes lui même la ferme plus
bucolique il ya un non sens parce que
les cultivateurs en avait déjà parlé ils
viennent leurs animaux ouais c'est ça il
est né le jour mais tous veulent
l'abattre
bien posté dans le truck pour l'envoyer
à l'abattoir en plus nombreux il y avait
dans le livre comment voir son steak
comme un animal mort l'attend déjà parlé
ce livre il y avait une histoire le
gosse était un
c'est un éleveur de porcs je pense que
c'était le gars c'est un éleveur de porc
puis il devenu vegan du jour au
lendemain parce qu'à amener il ya mené
ces ports à l'abattoir put your eye
contact avec un kill kill apprécié est
qu'ils les mêmes qui avait sa confiance
passe quelque chose d'aussi intelligent
qu'un chien un chien si affectueux puis
ils ont eu un contact le lui et comme ya
paniqué par ce qui indiquerait ça fait
un mois que je l'élève que je vois le
nourrir que je le flap que je laime puis
le dans les vies dit son père régresse
d'avoir fini sa journée
vu une conscience en arrière des yeux de
noyon le exact si on a un groupe d'amis
qui ont que ce feu de paille c'est un
cochon cochons miniatures qui
domestiques les rangs du groupe qui
pittier christophe rayé gêné vis
christopher quand tu rentres chez eux et
comme il va se cacher derrière sa mère
parce que sa mère c'est la seule qui
peut le prendre 500 ha et parce qu'elle
était abusée par le passé et qui va se
cacher derrière sa mère pilar plus la
soirée avance puis d'état cosmique soit
là il vient le m16 a beau sachant que tu
donnes des très petits mais lui
christophe eux c'est un cochon comme
tout ce qui était sur le toit en train
de se noyer dans lafarge but et puis
quand tu réalises c'est qu'un petit fait
phoques qui déjà qu est ce qu on lit ce
n'est vraiment plus de facilité d'avoir
de l'empathie pour une personne ou un
animal qui est un million de wii ce
qu'on mange du poulet - commenge pour
albert ii pour le secteur - enfin dans
un restaurant bonjour c'est le lapin il
s'appelait rabat veut pas manger un
animal veulent manger de la nourriture
un spike lee on apprend que tant de
milliers d'émigrants à syriens sont
morts noyés
ta voix une photo d'un petit gars sa
plage puis ça change a monté ses glands
c'est clair on éclaire sans avoir le
lien car c'est une statistique csn
touche moins on prend du recul
zoomer à l'envi peut regarder ce qui se
passe quand même qu'un drone comme avec
tf1 il faut regarder ce qui se passait
rien ça peut être avec nous c'est un
cousin et n'y est le mythique qu'est ce
qui nous dit qu'il ya un rapport avec
les problèmes climatiques ndiaye c'est
le moyen terme
ouais parce que quand on suit le
cheminement des garçons vincent est
causée par une sécheresse les jeunes
immigrés vers la ville de nombreuses
populations demandent le liquide l'un
des religions se mettent à chicaner
parce que trop de monde on se marche sur
les pieds
ça décolle comme ça ça décolle pascal et
j'ai vu une crise en quelque part qui
sont toutes migrer vers la ville puis
sont ramassés le ccdh manqué des
répercussions ce succès a réussi avec
les changements climatiques
juste les ressources ne perçaient de
ressources pour nourrir tout le monde
la planète il estime que ce vin
contenait la focus et les pois chiches
la place de faire pousser de soyaux en
génique pour novelli byte maintenant y
voir un problème le la chine elle sera
molle il y en a de l'argent pour acheter
du pain
l'appareil produit ces déchets pas en
chine m'a donné il ne rapide place et
des chinois qui vient d'acheter des
terres au québec qui loue des terres au
québec population mondiale depuis les
années 60 population double c'est fou ce
consommation bien les quadruples et
quadruples et on voit pas l'échelle
parce qu'on ne parte on veut juste qui
se passe à l'épicerie par ipsos reid
pour garder son niveau planétaire parce
que la planète est rendue petites
mairies maisons qui s'est justement
l'espace devient une des ressources les
plus convoités - mission ne on ne pas
savoir quoi en faire c'est l'espace qui
frôlait les lakers ne laisse pas la
place
l'endroit est ce parce que on défriche
pour nourrir le bétail
quand tu les greens forest hors des
friches l'espace d'un terrain de
football passe par un paraguay
c'est le poumon de l'attaquant est assez
pour faire pousser des pins
lyon tente de soyaux pour north et les
bas normands gelé buy way c'est tout
c'est toutes interreliées mais moi je
fais la méditation je m'intéresse au
bouddhisme depuis des années c'est le
souverain toujours mal se regarde toute
la bataille se passe quand celle des
méditations vraiment randonnée prend du
recul
penser c'est qu'on dise que c'est comme
des sédiments ballon compris les
sédiments se déposent dans le fond de
l'eau l'eau devient clair mais quand ils
baignent dans un étang qui brasse dames
1 sous ce capot de leur donner les
sédiments se déposent tu vois des
enfants pour la première fois ce soir
ok ça marche quand même pas ce qu'était
pensé arrêter de virer dans le bar comme
un effet réducteur d'été et on le sait
quel point tout le monde vit de foule
comme on est dans le jus tout le temps
oui puis les géants pas le temps de
s'intéresser compris moi je mange de la
viande pendant des années j'ai un sacré
dessus jamais afin d'être vegan les
enjeux le sauf que c'est générationnel
piqué d'astarac centres secondaires y
arrive tout les codes d'un coupé je fume
je viens elle a beaucoup ont fait tout
le monde
tout le monde a au moins un an fin
offrait femmes deux ou trois mois on
mange pas bien mais on m'accusait n'y en
a quasiment jamais mangé mes deux
cousines déjà 22 ans depuis qu'ils sont
petits été comme ça les a toujours écrit
il voyait un style qui plairait chausse
pas de famille le wild au le nom que des
années 80 quand je tape si j'en avais km
h est là mais les gens qui arrivaient
n'at elle pas ce qu'ils font là c'est
tout le temps gelé les situations même
lettre mettant comme dans l'temps défaut
est laid avec le grand mark et insulté
que tu m'envoies son ragoût de boulettes
tout ceci c'est complexe quand même pour
pour des mouches et mais j'ai pas eu
aucun problème dans ma famille il les
passait comme la moitié de tout ce qui
était sa tablette et vegan parce que
j'ai des cousines qui le champix et le
monde et au moins un intérêt chez un
seul mais c'est un chiffre d'affaires de
comme des chicanes familiale avec mon
expérience je te dis que le mans qui
sont le plus en maudit nantis par le
véganisme c'est des gens qui sont plus
proches d'être vegan que des gens qui
ont cheminé qui savent que sans capable
de manger de la viande parce qu'ils
savent que il faudrait pas carrément je
me laisse encore une réaction réaction
normale des temps m'ont dit ça énerve
quelqu'un qui s'en fout complètement sa
lena faut très souvent ces réseaux
sociaux la personne qui donne qui donne
ce trouble deux mois après c'est comme
ça vidéos faites moi persécutés j'ai une
fille chedjou vegan persécuteurs mes
confrères de travail
on voit cela dit je vais te présente
aussi c'est quoi la faire le match que
tu veux contraint que des familles où ce
que bon traditionnellement ça fait 40
ans qui mangent laden
un match pas madame ça face à
questionner ces quatre questions peuvent
compter comme tekken tag and mai et
obligé des questionnés petit questionne
pourquoi de fait ce sont des problèmes
visuels fax et d'un confort de ses ouïes
puis sa tête un tel point que mouna
temps ma blonde à ceux frappés par marc
je ne souhaite pas mais je pourrais pas
sorti avec une fille qui pouvait bien
ouais bien non plus probablement propose
sortir avec quelqu'un propose aux matchs
avec quelqu'un qui mange la vienne pour
eux c'était un problème aussi pour les
veillées bas y en a beaucoup plus que
quand tu as fait ton vidéo de choses
pour cauet peu plus d'hommes vegan y
avait beaucoup de commentaires comme
ceux qui revenaient de fille qui disait
c'est exactement pour ce que je sais le
batteur oui parce qu'ils trouvent pas de
tout homme qui sont vegan parce que
c'est maintenant et je pense à jesse le
témoin l'éthique animale
ça me touche comprend les enjeux puis
jamais été je voudrais en recause et de
la souffrance sans questionner mais je
sais ça va au delà de toutes ces chez
qui elle a pourrait pas juste être dans
des tec quelqu'un qui mange de la viande
à wendel se serait ce sera un break
d'entrée puis moshi que je serais
capable de tolérer une situation comme
celle ci mais pour les pour les gens
pour qu'ils l'éthique animale et touche
tellement c'est juste impossible de
penser d'attac quelqu'un qui crée cette
souffrance le sait maintenant que tu as
catch peut-être toute ta vie plus tu
commences à t'entraîner en full eu le
dessous du crossfit le savez un athlète
incroyable bête sur un contre europe une
fille qui fout rien puisqu'elle était
croche patte et tout comme tout sur le
terrain comme dans une nouvelle sphère
le way et partager ta vie quelqu'un qui
partage ses fondamentaux fois par jour
pas trop ce que c'est clair si tu veux
juste ça c'est un bon incitatif pour les
gueules le plein vegan c'est le batteur
fille qui a trait au contact
cinq ans au contact de cette crise on
est habillé autant de vigueur plus
exclusifs et au début tout le monde en
parle dessus il est issu un avant/après
incroyable ouais ouais sérieusement le
moi j'étais en france quand on imprime
ouais bah quand j'avais des activités
cette année mais bâle et young avions
tout proche orient notamment d'un passe
temps c'est toi qui es fait les
démarches pour les râteaux et pourquoi
ce timing la jetée ouest avec le
festival vigan braquet les émission tout
le monde en passant d'un gros sur
l'actualité souvent ça se décide pas six
mois d'avancé sur marco que les invités
semaine ya quelque chose parfois par des
pasteurs sur ce nouveau livre le nom
c'est ce que je te porte parole cheveux
solveig du seuil d'autres émissions
aussi mais j'entends pas autant parler
des autres émissions
michel bonjour bonjour du résultat net
de radio aussi très intéressant parce
qu'il s'appelle plus en profondeur
mais comme on en parle moi je savais que
ça allait avoir un impact mais pas à ce
point nous annonçons un peu mais je
pense qu'il ya l'histoire du monde qui
ont moins d'impact qu'est ce que toi tu
as eu parce que tu es des entrevues à
tout le monde en parle on en voit
souvent on en voit plein commis par
semaine le tissu social par semaine mais
la tienne à vraiment stand out le
traiter comme celle du pharmacien veste
en date certaine qu'on se souvient qui
marque la machine aura plus de l'avoir
vu je me rappelais que cette gueule je
l'avais gugelmann dépendrait que google
que quand tu tombes tout le monde n'a
pas troqué ses responsabilités oui parce
qu'ils te réponds à éviter si c'était
pour david latour domaine et faisait
standing social c'est comme ça c'est la
tv - dont on est sur internet le bal
fans
[Musique]
la tv a également dit la tvc des jeunes
lors janot parité des jeunes c'est
démocratique
je sature monde comme si en commanditant
tout parle à tout le moins de but ce
n'est pas de parler à ma gang ce temps
là tout le monde sait que des hamburgers
mon lit parce que je vais aller chercher
le plus de monde qu'un vieil ennemi et
vegan niveau trouver mes recettes même
qu'aux études mais c'est ce qui c'est ce
que je trouve génial avec mettons nos
abonnés à nous qui était juste du monde
complètement mesrine puis le monde que
tu vas chercher justement avec des
masseurs avec sa famille sont 6 4
enfants puis sont comme ma soeur ça fait
quatre mois qui a pas manger de viande
puis à le ton les puits a fêté ainsi je
pense tout à ma belle soeur qu'il
embauche de deux enfants pas son
épicerie que de prendre un george w je
pense à elle quand je tiens une recette
ce que je pourrais péter de la broue un
phare comme d'autres chefs joie m dugas
l'engueulade d'un objet de la new york
cherchait d'un quartier chinois face à
moi ça me décourage quand je bois c'est
ce que j'aime ce qu'un stream joue entre
ces trois ans j'ai tout chez nous je
n'ai pas besoin d'aller à l'épicerie
incroyable aux autres qu'on a écrit les
recettes pour notre livre ont proposé
des recettes aux éditions play lé chef
laboy c'est l'équilibré au final il ya
travaillé puis la règle c'était autres
leurs bureaux sont à stoneham puis la
règle c'était site vous nous propose une
recette qui on peut pas trouver tous les
ingrédients qui gérera stoner on la met
pas dans le livre joue pas c'est ce
qu'on va les chercher chez les jeunes
normaux ouais les gens normaux que des
gens normaux maintenant sont
sensibilisés sur l'environnement sur des
chars électrique emprunt les gens
normaux en guinée mais ils savent juste
des environnementalistes qui achètent
des voitures électriques ne fait que ça
va être la même chose avec la viande les
gens le grand public
il commence à être court et le plus
arrêtez de manger du week-end méthodes
dans tu vois ce cas matip à savè transit
ou dans dix ans dans 20 ans maintenant
moins de bascule incroyable que ça moi
je pense que c'est imminent 2019 ça va
être une grosse année c'est la cigarette
d'atteindre mais je me rappelle qu'un
tel arrêté de fumer d'un restaurant ça
parce que jamais les cigarettes asta
drame un martien ouais moi je pense
qu'il va avoir qui va avoir des réformes
légales mais si c'est arrivé et c'est ce
aussi parce que on met beaucoup de
responsabilités sur l'individu là-dedans
change exceptionnels en a mais il ya une
limite à ce que l'initiative face aux
gaiters s'ils arrivent à l'aloe le
marché s'adapte intervention à vos
financier une beau manhattan groupe
étudié les gènes de l'argent forex et on
va faire ce gouvernement suit est le
cannabis est illégal site le canada en
est une société qui va être un leader la
tâche certains parce que robert la
frontière pour légal partout le cannabis
le cannabis rsv ya ça veut dire que
c'est le gros bon sens qui est en train
de prendre toute la place
soit pile mur de berlin est tombé
mais je ne voyais pas ça venait peintes
aux gens leur chute du mur de berlin
c'est imminent d'un soir et demain avec
le véganisme parce que c'est
générationnel générationnel 50 % ni
vegan au canada emboîtent 35 et 50% des
gens au gouvernement son vegan t on en
parlait avec adrien dubois kaki venu sur
le podcast ci j'ai posé la question est
ce que lui disait of love que certaines
institutions prennent en charge le
changement parce que c'est pas l'un
c'est tu peux reprocher à l'individu de
certains choix mais éventuellement ça va
être juste mais ton pour l'environnement
vous sauver les meubles et rotor déjà il
faudrait faire un changement puis bien
mais j'ai l'impression que ça va passer
bientôt par des lillois fond qu'est ce
tu peux faire c'est tu dis aujourd'hui
c'est interdit de manger la viande les
coasters et la guerre civile
mais quand les gens qui sont au pouvoir
veillant dans ça vous changera guère les
bandes avant mais qu'est-ce-qui mais
qu'est ce que tu peux faire comme
législation décote aux agriculteurs a
pour trame tranquillement être en forme
et leur pertinence et la bouffe qui
pouvaient y en a qui ont mis en main
taxer la bourse peut taxer la bouffe là
vient la malbouffe la viande etc est en
tout quatre fois moins chère que tombe
peut-être déjà je sais pas sauverait de
l'argent aux niveaux social site art et
essai de limiter la consommation que je
ne lui en ai un système d'assurance
médicament universel
ouais les statines calme en ukraine du
récurrent chaque jour un gouvernement
qui paye bonne partie de ce pique nique
dans le commerce électronique kg le
trafic et tueries moment et qui essaie
toujours de ta bonne helmand wendy o one
shot par mois ça ça coûte cher parce
qu'au bout de vingt ans passés en place
par mois
c'est des maladies reverser moi diabète
peut le renverser avec l'alimentation
vegas un croyant ça c'est le docteur
juneau à l'institut de cardiologie de
montréal qui disait de toutes ces
patients qui ont des troubles cardiaques
ceux qui sont allés 100% plein based
il ya eu zéro pour ceindre chute puis
ceux qui sont allés peuples qui ont 100
restant alors dans leur mode de vie a eu
100% droesch de rejoindre aix est la
différence entre 0 % et 100 % comme
c'est fou le sait même pas de
statistiques nuancé bon genre de 60% qui
dit waouh leur échantillonnage c'est
comme 0 st il faut ça va apprendre à
bien manger des frites grasses et
l'éducation qu'il faut faire une grogne
auprès des jeunes et après ça je te jure
que dans quinze ans en vingt ans les
gens qui vont manger de la viande avait
des périodes moi j'ai l'impression j'ai
l'impression que ben vite c'est comme le
monde qui fument ou ya encore du monde
qui fume depuis mai mais ils sont tus
pense quand même quand la limite fumée
jeudi at on pour toi scène du poids
planète tant que la fanfaron va être
amputé c'est moi qui faisais taper pour
lui pour moi ah ouais quand ce qui brûle
est trop de gars
oui j'avais il y avait un mouvement
réalise que quand tu avais tu veux tu
avais des gros chance d'avoir un sticker
d'internet un design tête à parier qu
est ce que tu dépenses du carrosse comme
trois chars c'est pas bon pour
l'environnement
le stade les gens se rendent compte que
la viande soit même à faire encore
baisser
on discute tellement des transports en
commun des moyens de transport
alternatifs on discute tellement
d'autres
puisqu'une tellement pas du fait que
l'industrie agroalimentaire est encore
plus dommageable pour l'environnement
que toute l'industrie les transports
occupe encore quelque chose cachée des
votes ça non mais surtout avec tesla et
il va le singel toutes les riches les
autres régions ps l'autre les artistes
est le tout le monde s'est rendu là le
choc 6-10 et 15 ans qu'un char
électrique ça allait
de défense et puis cet objet de bm
mercedes qui es rattrap un rattrape le
temps perdu parce que c'est ici plus
cool d'avoir un merci d'asobo maintenant
tout est hybride les nouveaux suspects
d'avoir un choc électrique
ça va être la même chose avec la bouffe
payante soir est exactement pareil
pendant 25 m jeudi dans 5 6 1 2
c'est ensuite d'accord pour la
californie ambani le l'a20 de la
fourrure ouais ben il avait la fourrure
inquiète chauny saget la production la
vendée pro c'est fini depuis foie gras
médecine la fourrure c'est parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup mais c'est logique dans le
sens qu'on ait plus besoin de se jeter
un colon le terrain au québec
la seule manière de wii survivent
l'hiver c'est la fourrure à chaud
grenoble et lille 6e annoncé qu'elle
nécessitait son luxe l'événement tech
sont même plus chaud maintenant qui est
certaine c'est chaud je capote moncef de
dax et fat agression et bouteilles de
plastique récent deux jeunes la bande
petite classe t11 adopter des plastiques
risque évidemment très jeune on ici si
on a des peluches ou même moins qu'on
veuille en jeu des préjugés face aux
veillées des préjugés face aux produits
vegan day au breuil on peut noter effet
il s'est rendu des compagnies high tech
au bout de huit ans de vue et amirouche
yangtze theissen qui achètent des
compagnies de force viennent parsons et
plus gros producteur devient vrai plus
gros marchands de viande aux membres
quant aux autres investissent en force
bien bien bien végétale à base de
plantes rien mouvement de société parce
que l on peut lire guez qui a aussi des
millions dans d'incessants ses foulées
de tcw l'a bien je sais aux états unis
mais boulet ok c'est bon ce que yann
moix
non c'est pas pareil pour parer aux tirs
pour pas non plus virer fou
sauf que c'est bizarre un peu défaut
justement à quel point on essaie
d'imiter ses mettant le big and rich and
beenkens à risques est fait référence à
la sauce au moins cela viendra venait
pas des animaux j'en mangerais bien sûr
goût
sincèrement j'en mangeais celle de la
saucisse italienne vers yens le père
honni viennent d'une pizza veillant
c'est mon pote mon allergie
il faut comprendre ce que c'est pas si
pour une allergie à la vienne en tant
que tel c'est vraiment un principe un
fait que j'arrête de manger des animaux
les trois raisons la santé environnement
et les diplomates animal souvent ce que
je vois c'est que c'est du mondial par
la santé les ressorts pour par la santé
cité vegan ok y'a pas de mauvaises
raisons pour être veille à jeudi à paris
par la santé ceci que trois semaines
après d'autres choses que votre banque
ou la santé
je veux jouer au cul mendier moi je t'ai
veillant à stoch revendique et au
contraire c'est complètement elle a
positivement juste la vierge du grand ou
tv yen ayant essayé j'ai paumé régime
pour maigrir nécessairement une fois que
si 30 par la santé tu te rends compte
que à l'environnement m'en foutais de
l'environnement je me rends compte que
les whites documentaire le et par
l'environnement parle de bien-être
animal
1 parce que bien-être animal ça changera
pas il ya un animal qui vont mourir
sachant de quoi y avait des mecs vont
mourir c'est indéniable il ya joe hogan
aussi un podcast avec un débat dans le
fond dit il un docteur et que ça fait 40
ans qui les gagnent que lui dit toutes
les études le consensus scientifique
c'est que c'est le meilleur
modèle mentation pour la santé piguet
qui est justement que lui fait des
recherches aussi yad'autres évidence
d'autres études qui qui viennent pas
ceux qui ça dure quatre heures c'est un
gros des bols vraiment de deux personnes
qui connaissent enfants
si chacun des arguments qui vont dans le
bon sens
mais il y en a un qui plus axb plus qui
sait vraiment qui faisait consensus
scientifique c'est ce puits 6e puis
l'autre c'est l'espèce de voix qui dit
oui mais un jour on penser qu'ils aient
la tête maintenant c'est qu'elle est
ronde des fonds on se trompe il est
maintenant prochaine à faire ça va être
ce qui fait que tu aies clé si si si
ceux-ci qui commence samedi gardois qui
j'ai deux alimentations qui vont faire
part d'un livre on faisait jusqu'à
certains jeunes comme un manteau tantôt
il est aussi chaud hypothèques des
bouteilles recyclées en incident
d'alimentation que trop exploité animaux
lannoy c'est ce que un c'est meilleur
pour l'environnement
c'est meilleur pour les animaux peu
importe si tu vis en attaque les deux il
ya plusieurs types d'animaux exact
sochaux a choisi celui le plus d'impact
sous un même soleil sur les animaux
aussi qu'on pût tant mieux si les plus
regardées faut pas les regarder
d'exister je sais non faut répéter virer
fou toutes les fois qu'un gars qui avait
gagné qui gagne une médaille parce que
peut-être sa génétique peut-être un
bandeau factor arrêté qui était tiré par
formé par m6 a de plus en plus que au
niveau de l'inflammation labour payant
puis au niveau du temps récupération
parce qu'on voit que les marathoniens sa
red bull tant la récupération puisque
d'une inflammation manger vegans hainaut
chevauchent arrow qui est de mes lèvres
je voudrais tennis adultes un
marathonien il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
l'ultra marathonien marine théâtre si j
en a beaucoup mais ian e encore plus
qu'ils sont pauvres
ouais c'est ce pc ça sera la proportion
égale dans le monde on pourra voir
vraiment sauf au point non plus
foncez données pizza cause de tso
facteurs sont maintenant que jamais fait
de sport même si devient viviani
il sera construit là j'avais vu van ninh
article passé c'était une nouvelle règle
en suisse sur les hommages poussé le
coach par un bref aller qu'il y a plus
le droit de tromper leur mort depuis le
droit de les mettre
on les trempe y vivent dans l'eau parce
qu'il souffre semble que ça me paraît un
peu dans la bonne direction mais quand
même genre vraiment superficiel comme
cogis lation cac et 2002 d'affaires qui
arrive où ce pays est pire oui mais ces
cités du futur c'est ça c'est la
compassion qui s'était dite intelligente
daltin et le moyen âge le luxueusement
sa raison il parlait déjà sa place
publique ont reçu aujourd'hui des
barbares c'est la société évolue et
devient de plus en plus qu un simple
fait de plus en plus humaine je pense
que le stade supérieur d'évolution au
niveau du manque d'un stade où ce qu'il
y aura plus de guerre leur but mais ça
commence a clairement commencé la
société la ligne d'eau qui le lie au
mans puis c'est accepter comme le monde
n'est pas aucun agriculteur doit faire
alors peut-être qu'il ya une coupe qui
ont fâché parce que c'est compliqué on
s'entend que c'était ok bougie mouchée
du sud je me suis dit ouh la différence
que ça fait quand même temps qui s'étire
17 à 19 ans mais je comprends qu'ils
aient dalphond si c'est un signe de
changement
tranquille mais dans l'espèce de gros la
bile contre l'epa et des plastiques
laitiers - jean-louis c'est vraiment un
pas dans la bonne direction mais je
comprends que c'est un désastre n'est
pas des plastiques métier il ya déjà
fort pire que sur pour l'environnement
le tir sur le monde qui change arrêtés
et placés que ça tue des poissons mais
qui mangent des poissons c'est la
meilleure façon de sauver des poissons
c'est pas manger les poissons étaient
comprends que tu as pas déplacé que tu
veux plus parce que ça tue des poissons
pid dans un marché vraiment juste larter
de saumon mais pas longtemps on avait
des sacs de plastique et d'épicerie des
sacs et des sacs de plastique comme ça à
penser les gens trop belle
maj propose comme si cet échange se fait
pas longtemps parce qu'avec
l'information les gens avec l'éducation
l'éducation je mets tous accessibles
avec internet sur vous ce qui se pense
comme the bourne legacy l'abattoir avec
des murs de voir on serait peut-être
déjà l'oeil en ont des moeurs de voir
que les gens sont peu idiot un jean il
vous est ce qui se passe
l'espace les pays totalitaires et blogs
internet il bloque internet parce que
c'est l'éducation qui fait que les gens
ils changent puisse aborder révolution
et ça c'est l'éducation séparer pression
c'est poli le web c'est pas des
mouvements de société
ces classes mais c'était une bonne
course de poneys ivg y tient pas sur des
zones qui vais jeter ses premiers pile
en voyageant dans le temps ses 356 sa
femme linda mccartney accord des
produits mon ex femme a sorti des
produits bio issus des années qu'ils
sont il ya un mais seulement
c'est des philosophes
oui un discours qui était vg aujourd'hui
les offres de la grèce antique de la
rome impériale tipi mais surtout de la
renaissance
c'est pourquoi les religions c'est la
religion bouddhiste une religion qui est
beaucoup de deux ramifications
végétarienne ou vegan passé les gens qui
ont pris du recul
les philosophes c'est des gens qui
réfléchissent et c'est le job de pêcher
quand ils jouent mai à août il voyait ce
qui se passait puis revient développe et
dix gardes
donc on réfléchit pas ça c'est juste de
réfléchir juste le moteur d'une religion
catholique qui dit que les animaux
étaient mises à part sur une chance le
cinquième des premières choses qui est
écrit dans la jeunesse dans la bible
c'est sur une erreur sur tout ce qui
rend peu tout ce qui marche sur la tête
entre les animaux l'enfant ne sait ce
qui c'est comme tout à dieu utilise même
tout ce qui est en dessous si c'est un
frein si on le sent moins mais c'est en
france 2 ni souvent par les animaux et
imsa à traves pour les mange même ce
type aux pratiquants ou catholique et
fervent on a un fond catholique 6,9
alors le sont encore le ça serait ça ça
c'est encore présent même s'il encore
présents dans les plus vieilles
générations mais liquide annonce à faire
les changements c'est toujours une
histoire de génération des changements
sociaux c'est pourquoi je pense la
génération est toujours en mode après
génération précédente ou suivante parce
que c'est des changements générationnels
mots mais par un changement poule ils
vont changer votre flexitariens ils vont
manger plus de poisson à manger moins de
viande la santé mais ils ont été
tellement conditionnés pendant des
années que ça prenait du lait ouais ou
sur ma joue à l'erreur que j'ai perdu
espoir pour eux mais les jeunes qui
commencent
dans vie oui les lycées sujet à des bois
excessivement au niveau de la santé au
niveau de l'éthique animale jugé pas de
bol je pense le maintien au niveau là où
la santé subocz pas bon les délais c'est
le seul animal qui dut vendu les
clivages beaufoy de l'est le seul animal
qui portent des baudets tous ils sont
humains mais tu manges pas tout cas pas
la fin on est seul et numérique fait
plein de choses mais au niveau
gastro-intestinal nous notre système
digestif change peau d'un stalker 2 août
en impose une main j'aime rouler à
moitié de la planète qui boit pas de
lait sont ni tolérer aux produits
laitiers puis ont déjà fait mourir du
monde par les pays d'afrique parce que
pour les aider ils ont redonné du mans
pour les gens il faut que tu aies c'est
vrai depuis les anciens pour digérer les
il faut que tu aies sevrette est ce vrai
citant baudelaire en a 20 ans pour avoir
de l'aide soir ma chambre et mon ami oui
le système est fait comme ça
c'est ce que dans un dans une état de
famine est boiteuse les monos prépare
bord et peau d'une source de protéines
accessible encore chez vous une vache
qui mange ça donnait du lait semaine on
n'est pas famine nom au profit de l'e10
pasteurisé votre qu'ils montrent un
certain degré dessus les enzymes du lait
les anciennes même peut-être qui ça
aurait dû gérer en sait peu étant donné
que tu enlèves ben jaffar dans les hits
sera jeu des vitamines des cochonneries
date d'un oui le laisser tout bon c'est
pas bon c'est pas bon pour le veau parce
qu'elle vaut est un sous produit de
l'industrie laitière certain que s'il
voyait pas cher demain parce que si ce
thème en lançant dbrs crachin les
joueurs de champ pillages
il y va je les enlève loppsi janv un
bébé chauhan même un show avoir cherché
pendant les 25 mm à fabre une vache tous
et toutes saisies c'est le principe que
les animaux sont pas le bon on met notre
bon président mais si c'est bon pour la
santé le pays ce qu'ils boivent pas de
là il faut au moins deux stoppeurs aux
jo c'est qu'elle est allée à québec
renversante avec et anne marie roy
quittera nice tv ghana le premier co
c'était sur les produits laitiers le
consensus après ses enfants la clinique
c'est pour faire transitionner des gens
une alimentation 100% végétale puis
l'après le premier cours le consensus
était la première chose que vous devez
faire pour votre santé s'est coupé les
produits laitiers
mais en fait plus référence au fromage
pour le gru qui là dedans puisque les
styles du fromage mais son premier
combat c'était les produits laitiers
pitt et mettons dans le débat de dire
est ce que c'est bon pour la santé ce
que ce pauvre la santé parce que la
question est est ce qu'on peut trouver
exactement tout ce qu'on trouve dans
l'est dans d'autres choses qui crée paul
la souffrance
le taux exact
sitôt le choix du lait de soyaux
ardemment où les vaches qui causent les
souffrances
les amendes soient bons pour
l'environnement celle entre air d'examen
tout prendre en balance si tu es
intelligent plus gros bon sens laisser y
est autant prêté à nada oui j'ai demandé
le processus fondamentaux et ses
protégés à la des protéines y en a
partout mais façon l'ailé en épelant 71e
mieux qu'ils pouvaient un verre de
l'iton spaghetti à manger la montre
beaucoup de décès du batteur dire que je
coupable moustache de lait à tout et
elle a été tout le temps un graveur de
l'île belge a lieu j'en bois - parce
qu'elle est l'idée fait son chemin bois
et je me rappelle justement allé avec ma
pizza bombarder les 240 agents peuvent
être repeinte de l'argent chez union de
quatre oui je vais jamais devant douchez
nous l'a jamais su le livre d'eli je
sois femme allait donner des berlingots
de lait l'école normale dans un contexte
que ça guerrière les enfants c'est
souvent de plus le fait que la chine a
beat the pig luton lexique spacex
qu'est ce qui est encore plus d'argent
que le gluten parler du clitoris
je suis pas mal plus tôt avec le butin
que le vegas et là c'est le père a faim
c'est la chose à laquelle sa tactique a
été le plus
moi je voulais dénoncer le fait que
premièrement gluten défendant
l'impression c'est un mot qui veut josé
trop fort petit à petit je sais quoi
benjamin britten c'est ce qui fait que
le pain colle à qui cela protège la
gorge puis d'un taux de 3 à faire sur
tout ce qui fait de plus que les gens
retiennent plus loin et non parce que
une quinzaine d'années aux états unis
les géants d'y aller beaucoup de teams
fait récital à l'époque un grain anti
gluten scientifique c'est pas un médecin
s'impose une autre mais lui dit que si
ta main à la pâte à regarder manger du
butin si thomas s'était constitué la
démarche du gluten ça c'est le gluten
peuvent s'exécuter
c'est du gluten chassé du temps pour sas
et sata 6 voudrais ajouter du gluten
tabou en fait de la viande guyane avec
sauce incroya et qui sait juger un enjeu
zoug hilton finit par exemple à cause
je suis pour sans gluten m'amener disait
jésus était peut-être rien mais sans
risque on dirait jamais des cas pas de
doute assez seul butin savent sans doute
à pâques et dans la catégorie produits
dangereux comme le seuil haut comme
toutes les lignes qui parle de choï
aucune référence le produit tant au
niveau scientifique a pas d'étude
c'est pas parce que il ya quelqu'un qui
est allergique aux chocs et les
chaussons pas bon parce que des gens qui
sont coeliaque c'est 1% la population
fait trois maximum
alfred ans je veux c'est une vraie
maladie soit diagnostic est pas mort et
ma cousine et s'appauvrit c'est
dangereux puis ça fait chier parce que
il y en a partout du butin tant qu'on
reste dans mon incroyable puis en plus
les contaminations croisées letienne
boulangerie où que ce soit à 100% sans
gluten pour que tu puisses y aller tu y
es mais ça veut quoi tes organes
parce que souvent les gens dit ça coûte
cher en veillant parce qu'ils se
mélangent avec vega n'y pense que c'est
sans limite n y pense que c'est curieux
parce que c'est bio pense que c'est
juste du jus déjà exhibé gagnent c'est
trop sucrés militants de jules ferry tox
ccv gagnent parce que j'en dise à salhab
barça peut-être veillant noms reviennent
300 produits animaux ne veut pas dire
pas de gluten de moi je compatis je
sympathise avec les gens qui sont hors
jeu qui sont intolérants qui sont
malades sont coeliaque parce que ces
crises majeures mais de écrire sans
gluten sur des raisins pour en vendre
plus cher sauf qu'on se dit que sans
gluten par tous les produits qui ont
aucun rapport d'avoir du gluten je
continue de dire aux gens c'est une
panacée arrêter ça va régler votre votre
dépression s'empêche les gens peut-être
la retarde un traitement pour une
dépression que la personne serait
peut-être aller consulter un médecin dès
que le gluten pas pensé moi ce week-end
à des paires et c'est pour ça il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on dit quand on
parle de santé dans ce pot c'est
dangereux se désintéressa de l'impact
que tu devines sur youtube le pasteur
youtube aux stocks américains qui suis
auto tune
crédibilité qu'on avait beaucoup de
followers puis qui dit que le gluten
sont pas bons on a parlé le dernier
podcast de l'espèce d'aplanissement et
toutes les nouvelles peu importe tout ce
qu'elles m'ont dit pas moi que ce soit
pour trouver que ce soit un consensus
que ce soit une personne qui dit si ça
autant de valeur ces pays on dirait que
les moutons noirs
autant de valeurs que 89% tu t'y les 89
% qui dit si clair que c'est telle chose
puis on s'entend là-dessus
legault qui dit ne le dit je te vois
qu'ils ramènent l'argument des c'est ta
facon c pas en sciences pitié aura
certaine époque on pensait que la terre
était d'un milieu que le soleil tournait
autour d'elle moi je suis celui qui est
la vérité c'est un oui c'est toujours
c'est inattaquable
non mais non le gluten c'est correct
c'est le nouveau gluten qui évoquerait
ces hordes altun jésus
c'était des millénaires les gens mangent
du gluten non parce que je t'aime que je
parle du nouveau gluten lequel peu des
sources
pourquoi tu parles pourquoi je pense que
le monde se sent
ce sont beaucoup de monde qui se disent
intolérants au gluten qui luttent contre
le gluten pas mal plus important parce
qu'on écoute notre corps pas mal sauf
dimanche de bauchi champ ne jamais
manger doit s'effectuer dans le nouveau
restaurant manger de la pizza et
ballonnés ça veut dire que tu es un
terrain au gluten ou allergiques au
gluten phase des tests disent ok je vais
enlever le gluten mais je vais enlever
peut être le blé d'inde qui était d'un
pizza peut plus rien à faire donc
peut-être même tellement persuadé
quelque chose qui est si l'image est
normal d'avant je pense que les jeunes
et s'offre des gens qui sont intolérants
au gluten sont pas justes interac en
gluten mis en souffrance de base qui
veulent un problème qu'ils veulent
régler
il cherche on cherche avec le but c'est
taclait gluten indique-t-elle gluten
parce que ça contre la dépression au
sacré
joli geste malheureusement c'est des
gens qui sont en souffrance devrait
aller consulter peut-être pour des
problèmes plus fort du plus important
que le gluten
il chercha solutions dans quelque chose
qui est au quotidien donc je pense que
si tu peux régler nombreux 55 en dessous
cherchent toutes sortes de solutions
pour croire n'importe quoi des
charlatans y font leur pain et leur
beurre sur le dos des gens qui sont en
souffrance
c'est pas correct parce que la personne
suivant d'uribe job de six mois mais je
ne puis ce cas tu avais qu à des fêtes
chez vidéos lol tu avais été sa vts que
c'est ton plus viral
je suis pas juin millions de reach a un
mois pour sa vidéo le jeu un million de
ritchot ces populations tribales
c'est démesuré et nos réseaux que des
bastions digix de l'alimentation c'est
d'hélico quelqu'un qui est certain que
qui est malade pique ses sauts il ya des
gens qui ont passé comme quatre jours a
commenté jean je suis manquantes après
commenter tout ce que je faisais le
sujet ces groupes
c'est vraiment incroyable de lézards que
les gens pour ceux là dessus le monde se
répondaient dans tes commentaires oui
j'étais un espèce de débat et insead à
l'échelle reste parce que les jets sont
en étude
le lien autre qui sort un au titre des
études souvent trouvé des études bidon
saint-hernin tu marques tu crois sur
google retrouvé qu'un arc étudiant en
physique c'est quelqu'un qui est si
quelques portes qui donnent eux un faux
sentiment qu'est ce que tu as pensé
c'est légitime parce qu'il y en a un
autre qui ne s'arrête pas mais c'est le
contraire moi je parlais contre la
bullshit parlement compte l'équité
celhay n'entendra djediat qui m'ont
écrit merci le y en a eu
j'arrive à des groupes ce que pour les
gens coeliaque piste est positif et
trouvez ça drôle jonathan vidéo oui oui
puis 15 - si je t'ai coeliaque pour vrai
girveau reste à rennes je sais bien que
je veux pas de gluten puisqu'elle
savoirs partagés parce qu'ils aimeraient
ça fait quarante deux personnes qui font
une croix sur ses licences et vient qui
je comptais pas content puis caisse
avait eu comme backlash pour toi est ce
que je me rappelle qu'il a amené ont
jeté des fêtes une application je me
rappelle pourquoi je t'avais écrit honte
et c'est comme il ya vu un bout d'os
je peux pas faut lire les commentaires
des affaires domaine c'est quand même un
peu ton un peu comme ce qui était unique
c'est que tu réponds à aux commentaires
des gens c'est ce soir puis c'est un
statement de faire un vidéo comme ça
parce que les gens ont dit vote aliéné
une grande partie son auditoire par cinq
élèves et les vegans tout le monde
qu'ils mangent et 5 lutins qui pour le
coup je me spolier n'ai personne à bord
contraire on comptera ya des gens qui en
dia moi je te suivrai pub la bla bla
petit va gagner les sceptiques que lui
veut avoir les faits c'est un texte
intègre comme personne n'est pas vrai
que je commence à avoir une ligne de
parti c'est parce que je vais gagner que
du monde qui me suivent qui pensent
qu'ils sont intolérants du temps je
parlerai pas du gluten l'intégrité
j'aime bien mieux par dingue dingue mais
reste intacte parce que comment tu vas
avoir confiance en quelqu'un qui dit
jamais ce qu'ils pensent
moi j'aï le monde fei classe suis auto
partout il y en a besoin
c'est vous qui essayent de plaire ils
vont faire n'importe quoi pour essayer
de plaire à leur auditoire
faute de place attendait toi mon
auditoire
c'est tout le monde vraiment dans
général que je vais les chercher ce
n'est pas une jungle du web qui met sa
savez je me rappelle avait été ça a été
énorme puisque en était sorti d'être je
pense pour globalement l'ensemble des
gens que juste chic hôtel pour un petit
peu c'était une meilleure compréhension
par rapport au phénomène de du gluten
bien outiller les gens c'est sofia le
format chien kimo bas qu'il ya des gens
qui sont avec des études sérieuses mais
je postais comme moi mais moi je capable
d'en prendre les commandes
mais souvent ces noms conjointe de ma
blonde quant à vos demandes qui çi
dessus pendant une semaine de temps qui
sont agressifs qui pollue tout est
affable qui essaient de faire une
mauvaise réputation parce que trop vous
aiderez qui est de tolérance au gluten
sans contester les autres titres ostroff
sais seulement que je trouve aussi que
si ces cartes ma brave ou des
commentaires puis elle a évolué comme
anthony commune mais ces zones moi je
rappelais plus souvent le cas quand yann
qu'il sénégalais la caméra d'or par les
cherche des classes est ce que moi je me
mets dans sa bosse science tu vois
quelqu'un que tu aimes kxf attaques
étudiées - clp je pense parce que menés
dans une carapace sociaux elle s'est mis
à la poubelle répondu un peu mais elle
sait pas non plus son rôle d'aller
jusqu'à maskah manif obtenu ces médias
sociaux
sinon c'est fini tu ne te répondu oh
juste aux gens qui amènent quelque chose
à pertinente répond est heureuse aussi
je réponds d'habitude je réponds pau et
auch
des fois je vous répond de manière
humoristique un pote manière sarcastique
mais souvent c'est des gens il va juste
engagé des baux avec eux pour être serré
le projecteur sur ou leur point de vue
mais un témoignage demain un commentaire
sur les réseaux sociaux qui dit à part
rapport vegan c'est dangereux pour la
planète bla bla bla c'est comme si
prochaine à le désert par la personne
seule mairie se découragent mais c'est
un gage avec elle et y est content et il
trouve pas ça dure le satese pose c'est
s'est pas excité dans ta vie mais les
réseaux sociaux il est en demande rire
le puits des gens quelqu'un qui
viendrait dire ça en pleine face à wil
viendront pas de commentaires que je lis
que je fais jamais personne n'aurait
misé sur ce jeu c'est jean-marc serment
un thème récurrent puisque bastien qu'on
a le bon le tellement un peu de casse
sur 2 km
c'est tellement
un fléau société le coach et les
commentaires parce que les questions
ben oui je veux bien tout le monde je
reprends des questions ce fait les
gestes veille en question je peux te
faire congeler je peux dessus j'ai pas
le choix de ce que rouler tout le temps
il rester au top avec pour répondre aux
gens c'est que le podcast on lit tout
commentaire la grande majorité sont tous
ces films où j'ai eu mon premier non
mais c'est ma part et je te casse le
premier que sur soi ou li promis si
j'imagine qu'à manille cette habitude
mais au moins c'est quelque chose qui
était femme à lui factice c'est pas
quelque chose qui était quand même chose
une plaie couteau qui tourne dans une
plaine c'est vrai le premier dans le
podcast c'est le paquet avec gabriel
marion qui était double rembourse 30 kg
le premier dit que j'avais de l'air
nerveux que je savais pas comment me
placer dessous on s'en fout un peu aussi
il ya peut-être un jeu d'air ces
nouveaux bas de quatre mois j'ai pas de
dagana communication je peux genre on
est juste allé chercher quelque chose
doit se douter des jeux c'est ça c'est
quelque chose que la ligue se peut
qu'ils savent apporter un peu plus mais
c'est le commentaire d'après qui était
drôle qui était genre il a fait un arrêt
pont
avec la fille justine fixe tigers et
jusqu'à sa place en dedans
j'ai aussi parce que sans peinture leno
papiasse pilotes s'étaient ils essaient
de cacher sa transphobie c'est
dégueulasse d'adressé et loup elle a
écrit les gars comme ça ça me pue au nez
ouais mais c'est quand ça c'est drôle
basket et on évite ces notes parce qu on
avait dit qu'on veut je suis transphobes
je dis mais qu'est ce que tu essayes de
faire quelque chose c'est frustrant
quand et c'est vraiment du bon bord
l'ex-aof à lutter contre la transphobie
ou parce que je transforme ainsi si on
fait ça pour briser les tabous par koné
cette affaire celle inverse quand en
train de faire une attaque là-dessus
gentil ce c'est juste ridicule puisque
ce genre il
mais moins que les formats vidéo une
tente à la malade a mangé la viande
halal mahler et toyota systématique ne
mérite pas la caméra comme seule balle
en jeu sa joie que les coulages un petit
peu pâlotte de tous les sites et
l'excellent maintenant les jeux me
faisait dire se permettant des filles de
25 à 35 qui me temps qui viennent des
régions gamesdoglar maladroit c'est sûr
que j'ai pas une bedaine comme ton tu
fais parfois jaune orangé puis mais par
exemple il y avait vraiment des noms
mais il y avait il y avait une matrice
des madame ce que c'était c'était
vraiment ont détesté il s'inquiétait une
méchante et puis je te jure je connais
la peine de répondre non ça va c'est
vraiment que j'ai changé mon 78 kg
d'argent paraître merci beaucoup à cette
fin des avis maison bonne section pierre
ces gens que tu vas devenir développer
le foot c'est ricky martin mais je
m'attends comprend deux minutes le monde
d'accord by cécile famille a requis
mardi
ça demande l'organisation big-m plymouth
j'ai de la misère à m'organiser des jeux
la misère à avoir le contrôle sur ma vie
c'est faux je rajoute suzhou est trop
dans le jus mais je question de temps on
a trop souvent déduction une question
tant pis le sas fait petit à petit sujet
ce pas ça du jour au lendemain mais
j'achète plus de viande rouge à l'espace
une question d'identité tout identifie
son background avec tout ce que tu as ta
personnalité qui était formant une
vision de devoir avouer qu'un de ses
virées khamanei un flip qui se fait une
nouvelle identité que je me suis rendu
au jarret démener comme niveau mais de
tout conditionnement pirates en réponse
il les met j'achète bio dimanche que je
connais ont fini en flip est 5e je serai
par exemple jamais le bar sésame en
berne et on est on est simple il y avait
en belgique c'est depuis toujours ivg y
en avait un qui est ce qu'elle lui qu'il
pique à 7 le temps leur wild la botte de
foin salars bon pied total type il
aurait pu y rentrer parce que les
attentes au vu des gens souvent qu'ils
sont un speaker qui sont plus proches de
faire la peau parce qu'ils savent sont
rendus au niveau ce qu'ils sont
conscients qu'ils devraient faire un
changement succès des gosses pillu je
pense que c'est par l'empathie
multilingue qui naturellement ultra
pratique envers l'église manque les
animaux parce que ce
les gars on est plus je dédie sa star le
choix et on réfléchit puis on a de
l'empathie change la change
peyrens la conversation le ya 15 ans
ambitieux
les amis pour rien
[Musique]